un moment solennel cuit vocable dire
pour se souvenir pour ne pas oublier les
centaines de milliers de victimes d'un
massacre inhumées c'est la première fois
qu'un premier ministre canadien visite
le mémorial du génocide du rwanda une
marque de respect pour une tragédie du
passé dans un voyage qui met l'accent
sur les préoccupations urgentes d'un
conflit en cours
pendant qu commonwealth on discute des
effets de la crise alimentaire sur les
pays en voie de développement la russie
a bombardé deux terminaux à gré en
ukraine et l'écrire
la russie prend le continent africain en
otages dit la ministre les actions
illégales de vladimir poutine réduisent
l'accès aux denrées essentielles cette
crise alimentaire dans les pays
occidentaux elle ne se traduit que par
un peu d'inflation
a de fait devant l'urgence d'agir le
canada souhaite apporter sa contribution
on annonce aujourd'hui
250 millions $ additionnels
l'argent ira au programme alimentaire
mondial afin d'alléger le fardeau de la
famine mais aussi pour nourrir le
dialogue diplomatique avec l'afrique la
russie donc plusieurs années par exemple
quand même des certains investissements
en afrique en fait des efforts pour
redoubler sa présence pour augmenter sa
présence en afrique au moyen orient
également il ya une crise alimentaire
mondiale à cause non seulement de
l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
mais le bombardement récent de la russie
contre du grès en ukraine qui servirait
très bien à nourrir des gens partout
dans le monde justin trudeau a également
partager un moment avec le président du
rwanda paul kagame mais une rencontre en
privé qui était prévue aujourd'hui a été
reportée dans les prochains jours avec
un président qui est souvent accusés
d'emprisonner les dissidents et ses
adversaires politiques quand je
m'asseoir avec le président kagamé
demain je veux souligner comme je
souligne toujours là les endroits où on
a plus de travail à faire une
contradiction apparente qui illustre
bien les défis qui attendent justin
trudeau au commonwealth l'occident et le
canada essaie de rallier certains de ces
pays à la cause du craignent n pendant
que ces mêmes pays ont plutôt les yeux v
sur la russie et c'est christian noël
radio-canada kigali